so hello my name is Joe guidagno I am
from Phoenix Arizona uh I am a senior
director for a mortgage company in the
states as well as the Vice chairperson
on the.net Foundation board of directors
my contact information I'll bring it up
my uh Twitter Facebook LinkedIn my
website the jjg.me about there'll be a
couple links in here I'll start with
jjg.me it's basically URL shortener so
if you want to take pictures the sample
repo is also going to be on that GitHub
link as well as some YouTube videos of
things I've done similar to this
so the agenda we're going to first start
with getting started with Dev containers
then we're going to talk about what a
Dev container actually is then we're
going to build some containers and we'll
customize them then we'll kind of walk
through how you use them in Visual
Studio code then we'll play around with
a container within a container or
basically two containers together in one
project and then we're going to show you
an example of how you can use this to
open up your project on GitHub without
needing anything on your local desktop
outside of some form of internet browser
so getting started why do we need Dev
containers well it's one reason right
most developers say you know works on my
machine
Docker and containers tries to solve
that problem of getting everything
localized into one piece of Hardware or
software so that you don't have to worry
about the configuration going across the
board
so to get started you need two different
things basically Docker desktop for the
Mac or Os or Docker CE slash ee for
Linux now depending on the version of
Windows you have you might need a wsl1
or wsl2 depending on the version same
thing with the Linux depending on which
version of Linux kind of tweaks the
version of Docker if you have a working
Docker instance on your device then you
can use this
the other thing you need is Visual
Studio code although rumor has it it
works with jetbrains writer too I just
haven't tried it enough to demo it here
then you need an extension from the
visual studio code store called Dev
containers if you got started in this
really early which was like six months
ago it was called remote containers but
it has since been renamed to Dev
containers so if you go through docs you
might not see a lot that says Dev
containers a lot of it still says remote
containers but it's only been around for
like six months or so
so let's build some containers before we
build containers let's figure out why we
need to do that
so this is your typical environment you
have your
inner needs here let's get the
highlighter going
this is your development machine right
you need things like
the operating system shared libraries
that runs across all your all your needs
from development all the way to
deployment
but when you're working locally or on
your build servers you only need things
like your compilers your sdks build
tools those kinds of utilities like Ms
build and so on
but locally you probably only need your
debuggers you know the operating system
your utilities things like Beyond
Compare
Etc and then whatever personalization so
we're going to kind of show you how Dev
containers helps with this where you can
go from very beginning with nothing on
your machine to have a fully fledged Dev
environment with being able to Port that
over from one machine to the next
without having to install anything
outside of those initial three that we
talked about but before we get started
this is kind of like the breakout of
what Dev containers are
they all start with a template so if
you're familiar with Docker this is
basically your image there's a little
bit more to that but this is basically
an image and I'll show you some examples
of what templates are in a minute
so you have your templates and then
templates on top of that goes through a
feature set and the feature set are
usually your compilers your build tools
so in the case of a.net example we have
a Windows box or a Linux box with
the.net SDK then we throw features on it
like Ms build and so on and then the
developer container kind of wraps that
and adds personalizations to it how many
people here use Visual Studio code I
would imagine most of us do
so one of the good things about Visual
Studio code is that you can personalize
it you can add your own extensions and
plugins so what you'll see in the very
vanilla example we start off with I'm
going to have no extensions but the next
one I'm going to add two extensions and
we go to see the final sample which is
my blog there's like seven or eight
different samples
and that's what the developer container
is it takes a template adds features on
top then adds all your customizations
so templates there are about 100 semi
templates and new ones are being added
every other day things like Alpine
images dbion images C sharp F sharp C
sharp with Ms SQL
Etc and I'll show you a link this the
link at the bottom Dev containers
features has a long list of them and
then features I I want to say there's
like a thousand some odd features things
like the AWS command line the Azure
command line.net command line git Hugo
Powershell SC or zsh you name it there's
probably a feature for it
so let's go and take a look at those
features that's enough for PowerPoint
for now
and slideshow
and go to Edge
I use Microsoft Edge I hope I don't get
kicked out of the conference as a result
not a Chromebook guy or Chrome
Fanboy anymore
so this is the plug-in if you go to the
marketplace visual studio and search for
Dev connections are due from your
browser
gives you a couple examples for it
but these are the templates let's reject
all cookies
now you'll notice in the maintainer
column right now most of it says Dev
container spec maintainers that's
basically the six or seven people that
are in charge of the repo at Microsoft
that build this but you will see that
there are others
down here like there's this R project
that they maintain it and then a whole
bunch that are no longer maintained
which is funny because it's only like
six months old
and then you'll see others so you can
understand who the source is the ones
that are listed as the dev container
spec those are the ones that Microsoft
has built trusted made validated the
images and so on so it's just a word of
caution if you click on any one of these
it takes you directly to the git repo so
like if I go here
to the C sharp one it's going to take me
to everything that's part of it now you
really don't need to know anything about
this it's helpful to know if you're
using the containers to see what they're
built with
so that's where this Dev container comes
in and I'll show you that in a little
bit
if you look at the features
the features have a lot too now you see
you can keep scrolling this list common
utilities is something that you'll see a
lot of in almost every one of these
images there's Docker there's git
there's git large file support you name
it there's probably something in here
there's PHP there's node npm
Jekyll you name it there's a a plug-in
for it and the best thing about it is
you can add your own
it's just a source
so let's go see how we can do that
so I'm going to pop open Visual Studio
code and I'm in a directory that has
absolutely nothing in it so
as you see it's literally empty if I go
to the Explorer
and go to
projects where I opened it at
where are you see
in presentations right now close you
do
[Music]
there we go projects I had it open
before containers
so we're going to be working on this
directory container demo and then
container demo SQL so right now there's
nothing so I want to build a development
environment for net let's say I don't
have.net6 on my machine or net seven I
do but let's just say I don't
so I'm going to come here and do open up
the command palette which is Ctrl shift
p on a Windows machine or or a command
shift p on a Mac and then I am going to
not do that again
I am going to choose Dev containers and
there's a bunch of different options if
I go to Dev containers
I have add new Dev container
configuration clone Etc most of the
times you're going to use add Dev
container files or clone repository and
container volume and then every once in
a while a rebuild can reopen
so I do that first thing it does is say
hey what configuration file do you want
to use this is the feature or uh this is
the template so which template do I want
to use if I see similar to the website I
can scroll down and see pundits and
differences this one's in alphabetical
order the website's kind of just how
they're listed in the git repo
so I'm going to choose C sharp for now
hit enter and then it's going to want to
know
uh which version of.net I want most of
the times you can choose default for all
the options The Only Exception is as
we'll see in the next one
we're going to choose a different image
whether you're on a Windows machine or a
Mac machine that's really the difference
here Bullseye or Jammy jammies a certain
in boot 2 image where the default and
Bullseye work for everything else
so I'm going to click enter to choose
the default
then it gives me the option to add
features so what features do I want to
have available in this so a couple of
things I like to choose are common
utilities
and then the s or Zs H plugins
and then I want to make sure that I have
the get command line available
so I'm going to choose that
click ok
and then I can keep the faults or
configure options now the options vary
depending on what the plugins you choose
so I'm going to choose click the keep
defaults now one thing to keep in mind
I'm using two Community plugins actually
only one in this case the community
utilities the first time you choose a
community
lead device you're going to get a prompt
saying hey this is coming from a source
outside of Microsoft do you trust it
similar to what you would get if you had
a nuget package from an untrusted source
so ignore the configuration file for a
minute we're going to kind of see that
in the next
next thing we're going to do is
build the container so we do Dev
containers
and then
you can do rebuild and reopen which I'm
going to do or reopen in containers
since this is the first time it's going
to be built
need to do that so what's going to
happen behind the scenes is Visual
Studio code is reading that page or
reading that config file which I'm going
to explain after this and then generate
a Docker image so if I look here
we see starting Dev container show it's
going through and basically creating it
created a Docker compose file behind the
scenes and ran a Docker start loading
the volume then it's going to create a
workspace that allows me to connect to
local drives or you can actually do it
to create a container in here which is
one of the other samples
so once this is done
we should get a hey you're complete
right now you'll notice here
I have a new kind of blue box that says
Dev container C sharp that means I'm
connected to a remote container right
now the c-sharp one you can create them
any different name you want we'll see
that in a future example
and
as soon as it's built we'll get a dialog
box that says so
it might be taking an extra minute
because of the internet connection in
here
come on
let's make sure a Docker is running yes
docker's running
just hasn't finished building it
while that's building let's take a look
at the dev container file this is
basically a Json file that lists out
everything I've talked about so there's
a name this name doesn't really mean
anything for as far as the build is
concerned or the container but it kind
of points to what you see here by
default it takes on whatever the
template name is as you'll see in one of
my examples I rename it to my blog as I
demonstrate it using my blog
then whatever image it's using so if you
remember I got to choose what version
of.net it basically filled in this part
of the image with it so the template
said get me
mcr.microsoft.com
devcontainers.net Dash zero
Dash and then the 7.0 is what I added in
the features are those three features
that I added so you can basically go to
this URL
and copy this text here and manually
create that file for you you don't have
to do it through the drop down list so
this basically goes through a Maps one
to one with that and then these couple
other things we're going to talk about
in the next version
why is it not open let me see
for some reason it didn't run that step
let me create a terminal and see if I'm
actually in there and just yeah so it
apparently didn't feel like saying it
was done so now I'm in a terminal inside
of this Dev container if I do a list
you'll see there's nothing essentially
Visual Studio is or Visual Studio code
is creating a mapping
from a Docker volume onto my local
machine so let's go and create
a.net app so I'm going to dot net
new dash dash name and
hello deaf containers
and what did I get wrong
.net new oh
console
so now there is a folder here which has
the hello Dev containers and now if I go
back
to
that file folder now you see I have the
dev containers and the hello Dev
container so it mapped to my machine
locally there's also a way you can do it
where you don't need anything on your
machine and I'll show you that in a
little bit so now if I
navigate to that folder
hello Dev containers and then do a net
build
it'll build
and then a DOT net run
and there I go so I officially met my
speaking criteria I've did in my first
hello world demo
for the year and I am good to go
so let's go see how we can take that to
another
another step so I'm going to go and
graciously
actually before I do that let's show
that you can actually do debugging in
here
so I'm going to do a console.writeline
[Music]
hello Oslo
and then console.writeline
right line hello
NDC
and then I'm going to put a break point
right here
and then I'll choose the run and debug
and then a couple of seconds after it
builds
oh come on
stop being so finicky
just making sure it can build I didn't
have any errors in there
there it goes
now you see in a couple of seconds I
wrote the hello world and I got the full
break point
like I would normally
so that's a basic console Hello World
app let's take a look at building
something a little bit different
and going through a
web app so in order to save time I'm
just going to delete these
and we'll create a new
web app in here let's go to this
window so I'm going to dot net
new web dash dash name hello
containers web
uh helloneame.net new web
foreign
oh yeah yeah thank you
that directory doesn't exist anymore
so now I'm creating an empty project and
if I hit play
if I hit play or let's just do a cdn.net
run
CD hello
looks like I broke the terminal let me
kill the terminal
add a new one CD hello
.net
run
one of the things you'll notice with
this with an asp.net core app there's
going to be ports that are needed to run
you know usually 7000 or something I had
a little Port highlight here which tells
me that there are open ports
so by default it realized that Port 5001
was needed so it opened it now if I
click open in browser I get my
Hello World app
so that's cool another
basic example or starting example let's
go and take a look at the next one
so this one we're going to start with a
SQL Server
instance so I'm going to do Dev
containers add new configuration file
and do you see sharp and I'm going to
choose C sharp
and SQL same thing here
this is two C sharp seven
and then let's do those common utilities
again and
SCH
mitt I click ok
I'm going to keep the defaults
now this one's going to take
a little bit more than a minute as soon
as I click reopening container because
now it's going to create two you'll
notice with this one
is there are
or there were more files there
this one had a lot more files to it that
we'll see once it's done building this
one's also going to error out there's a
new quote unquote feature with SQL
server and ado.net that requires a new
connection string parameter called
encrypt equals true and or trust server
certificate and this library is not
synced up with that yet so that's why
we're getting a bunch of errors here
so we'll fix that in a second so let's
go and explain
what these are so we kind of talked
about like the name I can change this
name here
to Ms SQL NDC and then below here when I
rebuild see that but now there's a
Docker compose file and not a bunch of
images the reason for that is because
we're building a SQL Server that needs
different parameters so if I go here and
it points to a docker compose.yaml
let's go take a look at that Docker
compose you'll see this looks like a
typical
Docker compose file there's an app
section which says build it using Docker
file that's going to build our.net side
of it with asp.net
core Etc
and it's going to create a volume called
workspaces and that workspace is going
to map to the local directory
then there's going to be a DB command
this uses SQL Server latest if you're on
a Mac this will not work out of the box
you have to change this to
Ms SQL slash Azure SQL
it has a it's basically an emulator for
Azure SQL services that runs on a Mac
because this image does not support the
Mac M1 chips
and then a Docker restart if needed then
there's an environment
obviously you'd want to pull this from a
secret server or something like that but
since this is only running locally it
doesn't really matter and I'm going to
delete this demo afterwards anyway and
then the accept Euler which is part of
the
Microsoft SQL you also notice something
here it says add forward ports 1433 to
Dev container the force Ms SQL locally
so if I want to access this SQL Server
from any other tool like I'm going to
open up jetbrain's data grip in a second
to show you how to connect
so let's go back to the jet the Json
file
so we didn't add any features to it
because it's taking the the fall from
that image but now there's this
customizations
so this customizations will get mapped
to something here it's customizations vs
code so what this is saying is for the
app vs code I want you to add the
following settings so it's going to add
a series of Ms or Ms sql.connections
which basically has the connection to
the local server on Port 1433 using SQL
login essay that same password we had in
the config
and then we're going to call it Ms
container let's just call it Ms
container NDC so we can see
and like I was mentioning before there
is a known problem in this where
the port named or the SQL code
does not line up so I'm going to just
copy and paste that so we don't have to
see it this fixes the temporary problem
with
ado.net and SQL Server
trusted server certificate are you
complaint is true oh because that should
be
true like that
now
there's also an extensions here again
this is for the visual studio code it's
saying hey when you build this in Visual
Studio code I want you to automatically
include these two extensions so this is
the microsoft.net tools C sharp which is
this little guy here and then the
Microsoft SQL server
command Library so I can have access to
the SQL Server and because I know I'm
going to want to forward ports let's go
and comment uncomment out this
and I gotta add a little commie here
otherwise it's going to complain
and tell it that I am going to want 1433
also to be open and apparently I don't
need to do that I need to put the
comment afterwards
the last thing that's on here is the
post create so the post create happens
after the docker image is built and
loaded this is basically think of it
like the auto exec back or your startup
as soon as the image is ready and it's
created it's going to run this so for
the example of Ms SQL it's going to run
these three files here basically install
the SQL Server tools
and then run this setup which basically
creates a sample database for you so you
can modify this code to build out
whatever database you would need the
first time so create database whatever
permissions tables lookup data
Etc
and then this is not needed for most
cases but you can change the default
user if you have services that are
running inside your ASP and that app
that need to run under a certain context
you can save it so if I got everything
right with the configuration I can do
controls
Ctrl shift B
uh come on Ctrl shift B and then rebuild
so Dev containers
rebuild
so this will do is going to go and
create those instances so let's pull up
that and we'll see it running through it
should also run through the success of
building out the SQL database
and then I should be able to connect to
them afterwards
and I got an error here saying the
database already existed which is good
because I ran this twice already
so if I close this you notice right here
I got the little hourglass it's Visual
Studio code opening up inside of the
container and downloading the two
plugins so it just downloaded the SQL
Server plugin and the database projects
plugins those are the extensions that I
asked it to load
right here
so if I come to this one because I
already have the connection
settings saved here
it's going to pre-populate with those
connections
so I should be able to do that and type
in my password the one time
which was
you also notice a little prompt ah I
typed in the wrong password I can't tell
you how many times I typed in that
password oh it's because I literally
typed in the wrong password
p a s s w zero Rd
and now it's connected and I'm inside
that and because I opened up the port
you'll see here I have three ports
opened up I have 14 33 and I have five
thousand and five thousand two those are
assuming are going to go to
um
the instance of visual studio now you
notice here it said 5001 but it's maps
to local address 5002 anyone want a
hazard a guess as to why
it realized that that port's already in
use because I never close the other
instance here
of the dev container so this one still
has Port 5001 open so it's smart enough
to know that I already have that port
and it mapped it so if I close this and
re-run rebuilt the container it would
have five thousand one five thousand two
so now if I open up let's say data grip
because then I'll have the Microsoft SQL
tools on here
in about 10 seconds I should be able to
connect to it so let's go and connect
close
I'm going to go add new data source and
I'm going to choose SQL Server
and then localhost
username essay
and then p-a-s-s-o-r-d
and then application DB
and test the connection I should get a
green
man I really can't type that password
I had to come up with a better password
a-s-sw
foreign yeah I typed it right that time
so I click OK and now I have access to
it so I can use local tools that might
not be available so I've had like Visual
Studio there was something extra I
needed that was not available the
container
I can still do it there
and since it's a web app or since this
is just a database piece to it I can
still go to
a terminal and then ultimately create a
new
a new instance you know a new website
and work with it but I wanted to show
what it looks like inside of SQL Server
since that's since this is mostly a net
group
next thing I'm going to do is kind of
show like
as you have this and you check it into
your repo if you're checking something
into GitHub you can use code spaces
with this that allow you to
um
work with it without having anything
installed on your machine so right now
my blog is done with a tool called
Jekyll Jekyll is a ruby based tool that
basically will create a static website
and that's what all this is it's just a
bunch of stuff to get Jekyll working
so I look at my Dev container here
it's going to be slightly different
and it's slightly different for a couple
different reasons Let's uh
go to full screen
which is one of these buttons somewhere
here
let me zoom in
is that readable in the back
okay
so here I have it named you know my name
of my website joe.net here I'm using a
Jekyll one
Dash Bullseye so it's running on the
default box which is a Linux box I
didn't add any features to it
I forwarded Port 4000 because Jekyll
requires Port 4000 for its development
I could have did a post create so what
happens typically in postcreate with
this is you want to do a a bundle update
or a bundle install because I'm using a
default Jackal image I don't need that
there's also a post start command that
every time the engine starts it can do
something and a lot of times in local
development for in this case Jekyll you
would do a bundle exact chuckle serve to
start your web app but I don't want to
do that I want to actually start it
myself because sometimes I make changes
here you see I'm adding
six different plugins a markdown plugin
a markdown winter to make sure my
markdown's cool and then the ability to
add emojis because what's a good blog
without emojis right
and then because I really really suck at
spelling a code Checker that will check
my spelling as well as a preview for
GitHub Styles and then GitHub co-pilot
which I use a lot
now I'm also using another feature which
I didn't talk about yet which is called
the container environment this allows
you to pass in any environment and
variables so if like you're connecting
to a remote SQL server but you don't
want your passwords in code you can
create environment variables the same
way that you could in Docker with a EnV
file or using the dollar sign
um and then the environment and you can
change that
up here
under settings I'm going to zoom out a
little bit because it's harder to find
that way
and then here
under
I think it's no it's under settings down
here settings and secrets
I would click on
code spaces to show those Secrets now
I'm not going to show that because this
is being recorded and I don't want to
have to change my GitHub token but
basically in this section is where you
can create all of your
all of your settings
so now when I have this if I go to the
code tab
see this code button normally you would
click on it
and you'd be under local where you can
copy
and you know open it in Visual Studio
code or desktop there's also this code
space tab so I'm going to do is create a
code space on me
so it's happening behind the scenes is
GitHub is going to spin up a virtual
machine that's going to run Visual
Studio code and everything that was in
that container file so it's going to
make a copy of all the files it's going
to do a git pull and it's going to add
in all those extensions and about 10
seconds or so you should see extensions
pop up here
now the only difference between this
version of Visual Studio code and like
the one on my desktop is I'm not signed
into this one so you don't see all my
customizations but if I signed into that
this one it would pull in all the
customizations I had
in Visual Studio code
now you see it's setting it up and
here's my blog I get a message here
saying welcome to GitHub welcome to code
spaces you're using a pre-built code
space defined by the pre-built
configuration
you probably noticed that built really
fast and it built really fast because I
pre-built this knowing that I am working
on Jekyll or a certain image I told
GitHub to kind of pre-download that
image and have a server on standby
although it's not on standby so it knows
all the definition and basically it's
spins it up instantly for me and I'll
show you where to do that in a second
since this is on git I'm going to do a
git pull to make sure I have the latest
and greatest
which I was missing a file
and that's because this has been cached
with the build I built a while ago so I
do a git pull to pull everything down
but it's the first time you're running
it you don't have a cache server you
don't necessarily need to do the good
pull
and then just to make sure I have all
the right
plug-ins installed I'm going to do a
bundle install
with this which updated one or two and
then for my site I'm going to do a
bundle exec
Jekyll
run
and at about 25 seconds or so
you'll see port number no it's not run
it's serve
you see a port number highlighted here
this was the port number 4000.
it's building the site it usually takes
about 30-ish seconds and then it'll pop
up in a window one of the things I
didn't show you before is look at the
euro look at the URL
that's on here
Jake would dagno which is my GitHub
username and then probable Disco
so the uh
the dev connections toolkit has a random
word generator so it pairs two words
together and that's the name for your
image so this one turned up probable
disco every time you rebuild it you get
something different so if I look at like
Docker here
and zoom in a bit
you'll see that the recent one I created
was interesting Hoover
and my current website that I have
running locally is sharp Lamport there's
no name you can't go and change that yet
it's kind of annoying if you're running
multiple images but just something to be
aware of
and this is still running let me zoom
out so I can make sure there's no errors
nope still generating the fees oh it
generated them
so if I click here do control click it's
going to open up now the only difference
with this from a normal URL is because
this is running in a hosted service it's
not really
it's not really on Port 4000. so GitHub
does some magic this is again the jagu
diagonal probable disco whatever the
virtual machine name is Dash four
thousand
so wait says okay pretend you're on four
thousand it takes that four thousand
behind the scenes converts it so that
it's usable here
and then the app give so now I have my
blog working locally
and I can test it and validate that it's
actually working so let's go and do that
just to show we're doing let me zoom out
all together
let's go here and pick a latest blog
post so
the most recent one is way at the bottom
actually where is it mostly
should be a 2023 oh look I'm already in
Pages let's just grab
20 22 10 what have you so I'm going to
go and edit this one
and say hello from
NDC just to show it's no smoking mirrors
this is the visual studio file list
order
which is this one that's what it says
I'm going to go here
and commit changes
commit cheat or actually I'm not going
to commit changes I'm just going to I
can
we're just going to save the changes
I don't want it at it directly in there
that's a bad way of doing it
let me go back to
here and do it because if I do it the
other way it's going to actually
committed to the repo and I don't want
to do that
I just want to test to see if it works
so let's find that 2022
10 and say
hello
NDC
and hit save and then down here you'll
see it's generating a new feed for the
post and 10 seconds or so
it should pop up with the new one
and when it does
I'm going to click here and hit refresh
and what it does still generating
come on any day now
so I need to build a put a faster VM
when I'm doing the
demos so it's almost instant
there it goes now it's done
I hit refresh
and now we have the
hello NDC in there so I was able to
modify the code
right here in the browser
nothing up my sleeves that's why I wear
a short sleeve shirt today
so you can see that I can modify pages
online which is great because if you're
on a cell phone have to make a quick
spelling error change you can do it
with uh relative ease I'm going to go in
undo that commit so I have the full
ability that I would in
in vs code and discard it and you can
see I have the GitHub plugin which is
one of the ones I edit in
and you should see a spell checking in
here although I don't really have any
spelling errors
here
so that is Dev containers in a nutshell
let's get up to the
next part of the slide deck
swap displays
so these are some of the common
settings that you're going to deal with
almost always name features forwarding
ports most of the time customizations
post create and post start I covered the
post create in the SQL Server example I
did not cover post start but that's
basically as soon as the container
starts every time it starts it's going
to run this command so whatever that
command is basically it should be a
batch file if you're going to be in or a
bash file if you're going to be doing
Linux containers
so remember now that we have deaf
containers works on my machine it's a
devops problem now it's no longer your
problem because you got it working in
um in the container that being said open
up to any questions
yes sir in the back
how do you connect to your database when
you're running code spaces assuming your
database is not inside the container
right
oh you can connect to it just like just
like you would I pulled up a example
before
with data grip as long as you have the
ports exposed you can use any tool
because it'll pretend like it's locally
on your machine
so in this particular case I connected
to Port 1433 which is the instance of
SQL Server is running on Port 1433
what was that
yes localhost
yes localhost or dot depending on your
database server
uh German right there
desktop for example over any
any other Docker engine will work I only
listed uh Docker desktop because up
until two weeks ago I didn't try in a
Rancher but it does work in Rancher
anything that uses the docker exe will
work so Rancher desktop works
yes sir
so the question was when running the
database locally does it persist it in
the container the answer is it depends
and the reason why it depends is how you
set up the container so if we look here
in the
example
uh
nope not that one
yes exactly so in this one there is a
I think it's this one in this one we
have a
can or not this one the other one come
on Joe
I think I closed it
I closed it I didn't delete it but I I
closed it
in this one we have a
a docker
yaml file
here the docker compose we can add a
volume here to persist the data and
persist it locally the the difference is
with that it works locally on your
machine but if another engineer in your
group pulls it down they're going to
have their own copy of data so you have
to look and see you know how you can
share that volume if it's critical but
anything that's critical in between
should be something that's in your
script when you create
the environment all together like look
up tables and that kind of stuff guy in
the back
oh yes
the question was I mentioned GitHub is
caching the images
so if I go to the repo which is
this one
so in the repo no that's not that one in
the repo here
uh actually I close it because I have
the code window open so if I go to
GitHub
so there's two different ways you can do
it from here
you can go this dot dot dot here let me
zoom in
to do it or I can hit plus there's also
a settings here
under code spaces
where you can set up a pre-build so
right now this is my pre-bill you see I
ran it four weeks ago
and it's available in four different
regions so depending on where in the
world I am I get one that's close to me
so when you set up a pre-built
you can get a list of different things
that you want to do what branch do you
want it you can do it on Main or maybe a
CI CD build or engineering build when do
you want the pre-build to trigger in
this case every time I push or every
time I push it gets a new build
and then what I want to use so it's
going to use that Dev container file to
figure out what it needs and then keep
that image cached so that anytime I come
back to it it's ready to go
the pre-build is not there's no cost to
it from my understanding using the
actual container and code spaces there's
a cost to
but I think you can have up to like four
or five pre-built containers
the others
yes sir
can you set up what features
a git or a product rule yep
yeah so with those
um
the question was can I set up kind of
like my own tools and features if they
don't exist on the site what you end up
having to do is is making them part of
the repository and then pulling them in
from there or if you have your own
artifactory or jfrog or something like
that you can pull them in from there
unless you want to create them in the
public
uh git repo which I doubt you want to do
for Dev containers
yep
recorded your your settings for the code
space Oh this is a public one the only
thing I didn't show was my environment
variables
so everybody use this so
you can do that in one of two ways you
can do the dot EnV file
or you can literally show it right here
so if I pull a
if I pull another one of my repos out I
can show you that's not using it
so if you have environment variables for
things like uh
a SQL Server Connection or a user ID
password for something under settings
you can go to secrets of and variables
pick code spaces
and then just do new repository secret
and that's key value pair just like you
would in your environment variable or a
bash file or something like that so I
can do
essay
password
and then one two three four see if I can
type the other password now
yeah because now there's no pressure I
can type it
so
there's that
yes sir
is one set of features as an upgrade
you can essentially the question was I
started off with net seven that I did
not done at seven with SQL can I like
eventually upgrade you can you're just
basically rebuilding the container so
you're going to be starting from scratch
in either case the dev
the dev container file is just that it's
like a script that tells Visual Studio
code what to do if you started with this
a c-sharp app like I did in the very
beginning and then decided we need to
add a SQL server or a postgres it's just
modifying that and then doing a rebuild
so essentially demo 2 was a rebuild of
the previous one
I just happened to choose the pre-built
template
but you could dynamically control that
like uh in my sample one here
this was generated like this part was
generated by me
uh this part was generated by me because
I knew what extensions I wanted and the
way you get these extensions are from
looking at the marketplace
if you want more on like the file format
you can go to my blog and there's
actually
a
post I don't know localhost case it's
gone
there's a post the third one down here
that talks about like more into the dev
container
format and like how to use it with some
samples basically it's a copy of what I
just showed you on my
on the uh
Dev connections for my blog
and here's some other
things you need all the links I
basically showed you are on there
yes sir
in the last sample yes it was tied to
GitHub
um
I don't know yet the question was right
now the demo for code spaces was tied to
GitHub and can we tie it to any other
third parties uh rumor has it you can
with Azure I just haven't tried it and
done it
yep
yeah I would imagine that in the very
very near future again this has only
been in beta for like seven months I
gotta imagine that uh that Azure would
have its own way of doing code spaces I
know jetbrains is also working on
something where you can kind of use the
jetbrains tools to connect to it
basically behind the scenes is creating
a bridge between Visual Studio code and
Docker like live share does for visual
studio or uh
code whatever does for a writer
any others
cool well thank you for coming my
contact information is here if you have
any questions feel free to reach out
[Applause]